today's video is sponsored by warby
parker which is helping you get stylish
eyeglasses at a great price how many of
you when it's time to shop for a new
pair absolutely dread going to the weird
strip mall on the other side of town to
put strange piece of plastic on your
face in front of a bunch of strangers
it's weird no one likes it thanks to
warby barker you never have to do that
ever again they're committed to
providing exceptional vision care online
and in stores offering eyeglasses
sunglasses eye exams and contact lenses
if you know about warby parker then you
probably know about their free at-home
try-on program which is absolutely the
way to shop for classes in the 21st
century basically you order five pairs
of glasses to try at home totally free
no obligation to buy them at all and you
get to try them for five days if you
like one you can buy it if you don't you
can ship it right back using the free
prepaid return shipping label that comes
with it glasses start at 95 including
prescription lenses look my experience
with this everyone has different faces i
have no hair and a beard certain glasses
work for me certain don't the only way
to really find out is to try them on and
with warby parker shipping them out and
you trying them on it's the perfect way
to do it obviously parker has
traditional glasses we all know that but
they also have a wide variety of contact
lens brands including acuvue and
biofinity there are also sunglasses
prescription or not available to try on
at home and also available starting at
just 95. right now you guys can try five
pairs of glasses at home for free at
warbybarker.com forward slash
biographics so if you're in the market
for some new glasses check out warby
parker follow the link below support the
show and now today's video
when speaking of german fighter races
one name immediately springs to mind
manfred von richthofen the red baron who
shot down 80 enemy planes during world
war one but his achievements at least in
terms of raw numbers pale in comparison
to the number of victories of today's
protagonist from 1942 to 1945 he flew
1456 combat missions always outnumbered
and outgunned during which he was
credited with shooting down 352 allied
aircraft 350 soviet and two american he
was forced to crash land 16 times but
surprisingly he was never shot down by
his enemies instead he suffered
mechanical failures or was hit by flying
debris even more surprisingly in his
many missions he never lost a wingman
and his adventures did not end after the
war as he survived imprisonment in a
soviet gulag and later opposed the
corruption of the military-industrial
complex this is the story of eric
hartman better known as the blonde
knight or the black devil the deadliest
ficer ace of them all
eric hartman was born on april the 19th
1922 in weissach near stugar
southwestern germany his father alfred a
doctor wished for eric and his younger
brother alfred jr to follow in his
footsteps into medicine but the boys
would find that their mom elizabeth's
occupation was way more fun she was one
of the first glider pilots in germany
when eric was just three the hartmanns
relocated to china to escape the lethal
mix of economic depression and inflation
that had ravaged the weimar republic but
in 1928 the family returned to their
homeland chased out by the chaos of the
chinese civil war eric progressed
successfully through school while taking
glider lessons from his mother in 1936
mrs artman had formally established a
gliding school in the town avil im
schonbook eric age 14 was already
proficient enough to become an
instructor for a local knockoff of the
boy scouts much in vogue at the time
the hitler youth the national socialist
party had in fact risen to power in 1933
and as part of its rearmament policies
the luftwaffe encouraged and funded
glider schools throughout the country
eric honed his flying skills and in 1937
he obtained a pilot's license which
allowed him to fly powered aircraft in
the meantime he did not neglect more
formal studies in 1937 he entered the
gymnasium equivalent to the last three
years of high school graduating in april
of 1940. by then world war ii had
already kicked off but eric was more
preoccupied with the early courtship of
a charming classmate ursula patch also
known as ushooshi nonetheless an 18 year
old talented pilot could not be kept
away from the military for long
especially in times of conscription it
must be said that none of the hartmans
were sympathizers of the nazi regime and
dr alfred especially opposed the war
unleashed by hitler's delirious designs
of hegemony and yet eric saw it as his
duty to serve his country in a moment of
need on october 1st 1940 eric began his
military flying with the 10th flying
regiment he then moved on to advanced
pilot training learning combat
techniques and gunnery he graduated as a
lieutenant in january 1942 and between
march and august he lied down to pilot
what would become his signature fighter
craft the messerschmitt bf-109 while
getting to grips with the bf-109 he
could not help himself from showing off
on march 31 against all regulations he
performed a series of acrobatic
maneuvers over the zurbst airfield in
eastern germany upon touching land he
was scolded by superiors and confined to
his quarters for a week as he later
recalled the incident saved his life
while he was in detention eric's
roommate took on a flight mission
originally scheduled for him but the
plane experienced a crash due to a
mechanical failure the unlucky pilot
died instantly the event marked hartmann
from then on he avoided shenanigans
practicing diligently and adopting a
credo which he passed on to younger
pilots fly with your head not with your
muscles after several more weeks of
gunnery practice hartman was finally
sent to the front his posting was
fighterwing 52 or jg 52 based at makop
in the caucasus region of today's russia
in other words
the eastern front eric hartman would be
part of the titanic struggle of the axis
versus the soviet union
at jg 52 eric was assigned as a wingman
to sergeant edmund rossman technically
hartmann outranked him but amongst
fighter pilots official ranks meant
little what mattered was experience and
rosman had plenty of wisdom to impart on
the rookie officer rosman suffered from
an old arm injury which made it
impossible for him to perform the
maneuvers typical of a protracted
dogfight the sergeant preferred to stalk
his prey from above evaluating the
situation if an enemy craft did not take
evasive action rosman dove in shooting
at extremely close range harmon later
adopted and perfected this tactic which
he called see decide attack break but on
his first combat mission youthful
impatience prevailed on october the 14th
1942 rosman and hartman spotted 10
soviet planes rosman urged caution but
eric went full throttle and engaged in
enemy fighter it was a debacle not only
did he fail to score a single hit but he
almost collided with the enemy hartmann
then hastily sawed above the clouds to
escape retaliation consuming all of his
fuel with a dry tank all he could do was
crash land and hope for the best he
survived unscathed but his guarding
officer grounded him literally for three
days of hard labor once again he learned
from the experience and started to
listen to rosman's advice this allowed
him to claim his first two victories in
november and december shooting down two
fighter bombers the il-2 stermovics in
early 1943 eric was assigned to a new
mentor captain walter krapinski the
older officer gave hotman the nickname
booby this means young boy and it was
due to his youthful appearance during
missions krapinski would constantly
argon eric to get in the thick of the
action with calls of a booby getting
closer under the captain's guidance
booby's tally increased to 17 victories
and continued to rise from the 5th of
july to the 23rd of august 1943 the
germans and the soviets clashed the
battle of kursk this engagement is
remembered as the largest tank battle in
history with some 6 000 armored vehicles
involved but the presence of aircraft
should not be overlooked as four
thousand fighters and bombers
participated in total harmon and
krapinsky were there too unfortunately
for krupinski the first day of the
battle was not a propitious one he was
shot down and wounded but by now booby
was more than capable of holding his own
over the first five days of the battle
he shot down 17 enemy craft by the first
week of august hartman's tally stood at
42 but his unit jg 52 and the veermarkt
as a whole were on the defensive as a
red tide of soviet forces launched
offensive after offensive over august
hartman continued to perfect his
technique which allowed him to claim an
astounding number of victories at every
mission
harman's rate of success was surprising
even when compared with other top aces
of the time so what made him so lethal
the first factor to consider is the
sheer quantity of enemy craft which flew
in large formations thus providing
plenty of targets to an experienced
pilot moreover the soviet pilots were
surely capable but their fighter craft
were fitted with inadequate gunning
equipment their sights were so poor that
some pilots preferred to draw their own
sights by hand on the windscreen finally
harman was not a traditional dogfighter
and did not engage his adversaries and
protracted aerial duels he was more of a
predator waiting out for sight of the
perfect occasion to ambush his quarry he
would stalk enemy squadrons from above
then he would select a target plunge
from above and approach the enemy from
behind slightly beneath its tail he flew
extremely close to the enemy craft 20
meters or less and then squeezed the
trigger in short bursts before
disengaging to reassess the situation if
it was favorable he would dive in for
another kill see decide attack break and
if possible attack again these tactics
are best exemplified by one of hartman's
most dangerous actions and the one that
got him closest to death ironically it
was due to friendly fire on august 19th
1943 hartman led a squadron of seven
fighters against a formation of 80
soviet fighter bombers dangerously close
to jg52 booby and his pilot soon sighted
their foes tailing in il-2 he let off
the burst of 20mm rounds scoring a
direct hit he then banked away sharply
lining his sides with the second catch
of the day another squeeze of the
trigger and another kill but this time
the ace flew too close to his downed foe
and debris from the explosions crashed
onto his engine suffering a mechanical
failure hartman crash-landed into a
field of sunflowers the down pilot was
reassured by the sight of a german truck
approaching only too late he realized
that the two soldiers on board were
soviets manning a captured vehicle
improvising harmon threw himself on the
ground feigning a leg injury his acting
was so convincing that the soviets
loaded him onto a stretcher and onto
their truck when the sound of incoming
german planes distracted the two
soldiers hartmann sprang to his feet
knocked out one of the guards and jumped
off the moving truck chased by the cries
and bullets of the fooled guards the
pilot was able to hide in the nearby
woods as darkness fell hartman's
compatriots back at jg 52 were restless
they knew he had been downed but still
they hoped that he could be rescued one
man in particular could not stand just
wait by and see this was bilbao mertens
chief of hartman's ground crew more
importantly he was eric's best friend
against all orders bimmel grabbed a
rifle and set off on a one-man mission
beyond enemy lines to rescue his bro
unbeknownst to him hartman was on his
way back under the cover of darkness he
followed a soviet recon patrol guessing
that they would be heading towards the
german lines after a two-hour trek a
loud cry startled him halton it was a
german century but before the pilot
could state his identity the soldier
fired a shot the bullet tore through
eric's trousers very very close to his
jewels miraculously he was unharmed
hartmann quickly shouted i'm a german
pilot for god's sake let me come through
the sentry was not convinced yet fearing
hartman to be a soviet imposter it was
only after long and intense questioning
that eric's identity was confirmed and
he was driven back to jg52 that morning
mertens returned to base two he'd lost
all hope of finding his best friend and
could not believe that it made it back
alive this was one wartime bromance that
didn't end in tragedy
in september 1943 at the age of just 21
eric hartman was promoted to captain and
continued with his relentless streak of
successes on the 20th of the month he
recorded his 100th aerial victory by the
end of october his tally had reached 148
and he was awarded the knight's cross of
the iron cross by the end of february
1944 close to 200 aircraft had fallen to
boobies bullets soviet pilots now feared
the distinctive markings of his bf-109
red heart bearing the nickname of his
sweetheart oosh and a black tulip-shaped
motif painted on the engine cover it was
this black marking that earned hartman
the nickname of black devil of the south
soviet commanders even placed a 10 000
ruble bounty on the devil's head but
soviet pilots preferred to immediately
disengage upon noticing the black tulip
unwilling to scare off his prey so
easily hartmann adopted a plain colour
scheme more victories and more awards
followed in march 1944 hartmann his four
memento kopinski and two more aces
barkhorn and vice were summoned by the
fuhrer himself to receive the knight's
cross of the iron cross with oak leaves
according to eric the four pilots showed
up completely drunk and hartman was told
off by an officer as he wore hitler's
hat by mistake hartman walked away from
the meeting with the impression that
hitler was an unimpressive boring and
disturbed individual most of the pilots
in his unit shared the same view and in
general considered all nationalist
socialist idiocy
a little sickening harman agreed with
his commanding officer commodore hrabak
when he warned new pilots that if they
thought they were fighting for national
socialism and the fuhrer they needed to
transfer to the waffen-ss they were
fighting a war against a superb enemy
that superb enemy was by that time
winning the war when eric and friends
returned to the east the german defenses
were collapsing in may of 1944 jg 52 was
relocated to romania where they would be
employed in the defense of the
strategically vital ploy estee oil
fields it was in this theater that
hartman faced the us army air forces for
the first time on the 24th of june the
black devil claimed the first victory
against a p-51 mustang later in the
month he shot down his second mustang
but he didn't have time to celebrate his
eight american fighters gave chase
harman dodged their bullets in a series
of evasive maneuvers until he ran out of
fuel with no other option he released
the canopy of his bf-109 and bailed out
with his parachute as he was floating
down a p-51 approached menacingly at
speed at the last moment it banked away
sharply the american pilots and the
downed german ace saluted each other a
sign of respect among knights of the sky
if the american had known that he had
the black devil in his sights maybe he
would have decided otherwise but hartman
lived another day to fight on on august
17 1944 he officially became the top
scoring ace of all time when he downed
his 274th plane one week later he
surpassed the 300 mark by performing his
most astonishing feat on a single day he
flew two missions during which time he
shot down a total of 11 soviet planes
by now a celebrity the pilot was invited
to receive the diamonds to his knight's
cross at hitler's rastenberg
headquarters the wolf's lair during the
meeting hitler admitted to hartmann that
the war was lost what little hope was
left rested on the last ditch wonder
weapons developed by the third reich
weapons like the messerschmitt me262 the
early prototype of a jet fighter
luftwaffe general adolf galland asked
hotman to join the me262 test program
but the ace declined he preferred to
continue fighting with his unit jg 52
plus he had just earned 10-day license
which put good use by marrying ush on
the 10th of september by then hitler's
maniacal empire was crumbling besieged
on three fronts and yet jg 52 continued
fighting to the bitter end even after
the suicide of the fuhrer may the 8th
1945 was the last day of war in europe
but on that morning hostilities had not
ceased that's when over the skies of
bruno modern-day czech republic eric
shot down his 352nd plane a soviet yak-9
upon landing he learned that his
airfield was within range of incoming
soviet forces by now a major hartman
ordered his men to retreat westwood to
surrender to u.s infantry he felt that
they would be safer with the americans
than with the soviets what he did not
know was that according to the altar
agreement all their marked personnel
deployed on the eastern front would be
handed over to the red army and that is
exactly what happened on the 14th of may
as a pow of the soviets harma was
initially pressured to cooperate with
them by spying on fellow officers an
offer which he could and did refuse
earning him 10 days of solitary
confinement more harsh treatment
followed as nkpd interrogators tried to
extort information on the me262 program
harman did not cooperate and a
frustrated officer struck him with a
cane hartman replied in kind smashing a
chair onto the soviet's head several
months had passed and hartmann was being
held without charge these came only on
the 27th of december 1949 when soviet
authorities sentenced him to 20 years in
prison as a war criminal he was charged
with the killing of 780 soviet civilians
at briansk which he vehemently denied he
was also condemned for having destroyed
345 soviet aircrafts which of course he
did not deny but then again it was war
wasn't it harman was doomed to serve
years of hard labor in the hellish gulag
system unwilling to yield he refused to
perform his duties and was thrown again
into solitary his mistreatment led other
prisoners to organize a riot they even
managed to briefly overpower the guards
and free him from his cell they were
about to escape to freedom but hartmann
convinced them to stay put once beyond
the gates they all risked being shot on
site order was eventually restored
hartman took the occasion to file a
complaint with the commander of the camp
requesting an international inspection
and an appeal trial both requests landed
in the appropriate filing cabinet the
waste paper bin and the ace was
dispatched in the novichok gulag for a
five-month stint in confinement at this
point the soviet surprisingly accepted
to hold a new trial unsurprisingly they
confirmed the original sentence and sent
hartman to an even harsher camp on the
euro mountains luckily for him in 1955
the normalization of relationships
between the soviet union west germany
led to the release of the last german
pows eric hartman was one of them he was
finally able to return home to his wife
unfortunately he was never able to hold
in his arms their first born child eric
peter the boy had been born in 1945 and
subsequently died in 1948 while his
father was in captivity
[Music]
once reunited eric and ush could finally
lead a normal life they welcomed a
daughter ursula isabel on february 23
1957 and he was reinstated in the west
german air force as a commander of
fighter wing 71. the unit was initially
equipped with canadair sabres scheduled
to be replaced by the lockheed f-104
starfighters hartmann had had the
occasion to fly the starfighters during
a trip to the u.s while he admired their
performance he noted their frequent
engine problems and maintenance
difficulties overall he considered them
to be unsafe especially if flown by
inexperienced pilots he voiced his
concerns to an old friend general kim
herber inspector of the german air force
the general appeared sympathetic but
eventually cautioned hartmann from
talking about the subject to anyone else
the purchase of the starfighters was a
done deal a political decision taken by
defence minister strauss which overruled
the advice of experienced officers by
july 1960 west germany had become the
largest market for lockheed craft and
pilots had already begun training sadly
they also started dying over the span of
just five years 35 pilots perished in
non-combat missions by the early 1980s
when the f-104 was finally
decommissioned 116 pilots had lost their
lives harman's predictions had been
proven right but no one thanked him
quite the opposite his relentless
criticism had made many enemies within
the air force and the ministry when he
neglected to renew his pilot's license
due to an oversight his detractors took
the occasion to bring him to a military
tribunal on disciplinary charges hartman
was absolved but he was relieved of his
operational command and kicked upwards
to a desk job in cologne eventually
opted for an early retirement from the
military in september of 1970 working as
a civilian instructor until 1974. two
years later in february 1976 a u.s
senate subcommittee heard that lockheed
had been routinely bribing foreign
governments to secure contracts for
their f-104s 24 million 167 million
dollars in today's money had been
allocated by the corporation as bribe
money the scandal had mainly involved
the netherlands japan and italy but
according to a new york times article of
september 1976 german defense minister
her strauss had been receiving kickbacks
to the tune of 12 million dollars from
lockheed as early as 1961 but it was too
late to undo what was arguably eric
hartman's greatest defeat even the ace
pilot who had never been shot down by
enemy fire could not triumph against the
machinations of the military-industrial
complex hartman spent his last years in
relative obscurity occasionally being
interviewed and celebrated by his old
foes the usaf he died of a heart
condition on the 20th of september 1993
at the age of 71 in veal imstornbc four
years later the russian chief military
prosecutor posthumously acquitted him of
all charges as an alleged war criminal
[Music]
you